it's all [ __ ] oh my god hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to the attack on Titan tribute
game now if you recall I've done a let's
play on this before and I played in a
livestream but someone recently told me
that there was an update to the game
that allowed you to play as a Titan and
I go well not you but me more
specifically I mean you can too if you
click on the link in the description
below but that's besides the point
I get to play as a freakin Titan and I
don't watch many animes but attack on
Titan is one of the few that I do like I
was that full metal alchemist in Dragon
Ball Z back in the Toonami days but I
mean it's who would pass this up now I
played the other levels I'm just gonna
play on the first one and I'm hey there
he is okay and I like to play on TPS so
I haven't played this yet I am very ear
to give this try oh look at me I'm
adorable
I probably oh look at me I'm freaking
adorable
I shouldn't be adorable because I think
Titans are like what they're like um 40
stories tall or something I have no idea
but oh look at me
I've a dumb I'm adorable oh my god I
could jump thermal land on your head
yeah yeah did that actually know that
into anything
Oh what do you think you're gonna do
with your beauty little smashes can they
hurt me I have no idea what can I do
like a bosom I'm a bunch of LeBaron come
on here yeah yeah mister you want some
more what are you doing running off
stupid over there yeah holy crap did I
do
I did that haha wow this is the way you
bastard Titans deserve after what how I
hit this one this one's tiny how do I
hit him alright I'll leave you for later
but anyway they're like a control menu I
don't know if there's like any sort of
menu in this game
maybe there's some button that I can
press bear with me
whoa oh you do it were you doing excuse
me
good golly you you need to die
immediately why are you dying
why isn't he dying it's not dying he's
creepy it's weird
ah how do I get out I can't move whoa
that what the hell pieces yeah
I can't punch this one it's one of the
devian whoa geez get back down there
don't do that I can punch him like in
his butt but it's not going to his
basement swear I need to pound him
anyway hang on I'm gonna go over here
for a second hands leave me alone leave
me alone leave me alone I'm just a
helpless Titan I need to figure out the
controls before I do anything else um uh
would that do would that do oh my god
what is what it oh oh
I started over again Damon I forgot the
excuse me oh now my mouse is out don't
do like that don't do like that damn it
fine Stickles god damn it okay there
goes my mouth okay good we're back in
we're back in sorry I just had a minor
panic attack because of my mouse was
outside of the game anyway um I don't
know hang on I gotta figure out how he
did there you a liver this big
I'm not moving I'm not oh there's a
little Titan under oh it's a little
crawly one
oh you crawly bastard you're so weird
you're so weird I'm gonna go over here
excuse me oh oh you're still weird why
do I keep looking backwards I don't know
oh you're gay get out of here here hey
wait how'd I do that uh duh when I did
something right click okay right click
ticket okay right click the kick
where's where'd he go did I kick him
into next year I apparently did okay
you want some of this y'all look at
everybody go get tired Aaron song
[ __ ] oh my god triple kill bread
goodness let's go deep friend yes I
guess this is vengeance for all the
times that I died good golly I like how
I flashed inside of my own General
Grievous this is actually quite fun uh I
will not denied this really but a lot of
work put into this ever since it first
came out what are you doing what are you
doing
you won't talk oh don't my day whose
awful I fell down oh this is bad
didn't want to hear you talk not another
day little ones go flying okay if I
could actually hit you ah there we go
you on the ground turn around Aaron
you're so stupid
there we go okay that'd kill you kicking
only kills the little ones get back here
I'm gonna blow your head off to blow
your head away yeah there we go
oh man there's only six Titans left I've
annihilated them oh my god hey oh I see
you there don't think you can hide for
me what are you doing trying to run away
there is no hiding
not from Aaron not from markiplier Titan
market Titan I don't know whatever wait
T to restart he says there's one Titan
left is there nothing gonna kill them
all look probably the good oh my god I
did lose Jimmy you look at everybody
anyway it is did you get it with him hey
where are you where are you hiding
little Titans
uncle more gobblers coming to get you
does this tightens down a bit look too
much like Santa Claus to anyone you come
out come out wherever you are
oh cool vaca blur watch dis day hello
Mario
oh there you are I steal all your baby
watch turbo
alright so that was the update to the
attack on Titan trivia game this
actually is pretty fun I still don't
know if the multiplayer is working
correctly but if you got some friends
and you want to reenact Titan attack on
Titan be my guest
links in the description so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done it has always I will see you in the
next video
don't get dumb
good
hi
big ugly